ladies and gentlemen twist is back home
on Team Liquid to round out what looks
to be at least on paper one of the most
promising rosters in the game the only
question is even given that is it enough
to save an
ACS folks we all knew it was coming but
I can finally say that my favorite
player and yours is finally back on Team
Liquid I'm back and I want number
three
but twist is hardly the only new
addition so how did we get here back in
June TL made the unpopular decision to
move to a majority European roster after
the departure of a Le and listen the
team wasn't terrible paty and Rain Waker
are two very talented players but it's
clear that something with the move or
the chemistry itself was causing issues
it felt like a change was just bound to
happen and at the beginning of October
that's exactly what happened the day
after rain Waker was benched Kaden
reached a mutual agreement to do the
same thing on heroic to which we
immediately started hearing rumors of
the Danish igl joining liquid now there
ended up being this whole weird thing
where Kaden might have actually been
backstabbed by his own teammates on
heroic causing him to go back one last
time and play for them but we already
did a whole video on that nonsense so go
check it out if you haven't regardless
there seemed to be a strong chance that
TL was actually looking to acquire one
of the best igl's in the game right now
but then things got even spicier on
October 20th it was announced that FaZe
Clan was being sold now the for's
financials have been concerning for
quite some time now but for a moment
things got pretty uncertain and in that
chaos were rumors that twist would be
coming back to liquid after leaving in
2020 nothing was confirmed there were
bizarre tweets and other teams thrown
into the mix but it did seem likely that
TL was in the market for a massive
upgrade these Rumblings continued but in
late November after OC and py were
benched we finally found out who might
be filling out this roster alongside Naf
and yakar young Brazilian rifler skulls
and returning coach Zeus now although
none of this was actually fully
confirmed there was so much reporting on
it it basically felt like it was we were
all pretty much just sitting around
waiting for TL to drop some announcement
videos and this week that's exactly what
we got starting with skulls and Zeus now
Zeus should need no introduction he's
the two-time major winning coach of the
lgk Dynasty and is pretty much
responsible for building the foundation
of a team liquid that would go on to win
a grand slam skulls on the other hand is
a young gun coming from pain so I
wouldn't blame you for not knowing exact
who he is but to bring you up to speed
he's fing cracked and could be the fire
that this team needs skulls all by
himself they don't know he's here might
be able to get two out of this one and
he does hold on just a second skulls in
a one on
four following up those two was
yesterday's announcement that TL's new
igl is in fact cadium and last but
certainly not least to finalize this
stacked roster is twists twist has
accomplished a lot ever since he left
for FaZe back in 2020 he even won a
major and it's going to be sad seeing
him leave behind his pal robs but
whether it was the potential uncertainty
of fa's future or just the prospect of
being able to come home twist has
reunited with Naf and we couldn't be any
happier now with all the rumors laid to
rest and the team finally finalized we
have one question as we know with a now
technically majority Canadian roster
Team Liquid is back in the North
American RMR so can they bring this
region back to its Glory Days obviously
we won't know until they start playing
but I am hopeful on paper this team
slaps and I mean we already know that
Naf and yakar are fantastic players but
with yakar getting all of his igl
responsibilities lifted from his
shoulders he can go back to killing
which you know is what he does best and
love him or hate him but Kaden is a damn
good igl sure he came runner up a lot on
heroic but he also accomplished more
than most TL has historically struggled
with sorting out the igl duties but with
Kaden I just don't really see that
happening I think I think we finally
have a guy who can take the wheel and
steer this ship you kinderart pretty
well said as much in this Tweet now
skulls is a very mechanically skilled
young player with a bright future and
under the right guidance of his team
especially Zeus he has a ton of
potential and as far as twist goes I
don't know what else to say the guy is
as good as he's ever been look all of
the pieces are there for a very very
talented team now it's just up to them
to put it together now I know I'm
excited but I want to hear from all of
you does this team have what it takes to
bring us another major or is the
pressure just too high I don't know if
I've told my twist story before but I
went to Vancouver during the wildfires a
few years ago and I went on a whale
watching orca watching tour and uh he
sat beside us and I didn't say a single
word to him cuz well I I like said
things to him but I did not like
introduce myself or like make it clear
that I knew who he was